it's hard to be excited about the
benefits of a cucumber but
let's talk about cucumbers in general
now sometimes i will switch it up
instead of having a big salad i'll have
a couple cucumbers and
it's interesting because the cucumber
has 73
different phenolic compounds which are
just a type of phytonutrient
and another unique thing about cucumbers
is they have certain phytonutrients
that are in cruciferous vegetables but
not in other vegetables
except cucumbers now there's five basic
benefits from cucumbers health-wise they
help stabilize your blood sugars
they help stabilize your cholesterol by
helping reduce ldl increasing hdl
decreasing triglycerides also they're a
good anti-inflammatory
they are loaded with antioxidants very
powerful antioxidants
all these right here and plus they
provide fiber to make
butyrate so your microbes can take that
fiber and turn it into
small chain fatty acids and this helps
with insulin resistance it feeds the
colon cells
it gives the colon cells energy now the
question is how do we extract these
phytonutrients and a lot of them are fat
soluble
now in order to extract these from
plants
there's three main things you can do
one is you can ferment
them okay when you ferment a vegetable
now that's different from pickling which
i'll talk about in a second
when you ferment them you actually
release
more phytonutrients you make more
phytonutrients available for you
to use so when you go to the grocery
store
the great majority of pickles
are basically just cucumbers with some
added acid
when you do that you do not enhance the
phytonutrients you don't
make them more available now
when you eat pickled anything it's going
to help your digestion to some degree
but you're not going to get the maximum
benefits of getting these right here
but when you ferment them you will
so one of the brands that i recommend is
bubbies pickles they have sauerkraut
really high quality product and that's a
true fermented product
where they add a bacteria lactobacillus
and then what happens it ferments the
carbohydrate
and you get lactic acid it takes longer
but you have the release of these
phytonutrients so
i would always recommend if you're going
to eat pickles go with the fermented
pickles it should say it right on the
label you'll just get more
health benefits so that's the first way
to extract these
fat soluble phytonutrients from
vegetables the next way is to steam them
a little bit
don't overcook them but when you steam
them you will also release
some of the phytonutrients which is
interesting and the last thing you can
do
is you could eat them with fat and what
i do is i do cucumbers with
hummus not the typical hummus that has
the soy oil
or even the safflower oil i want it with
the olive oil
so i get my hummus from the farmer's
market or i will go to a healthy store
to find it
but adding some of the tahini butter
which isn't
a fat with cucumber will help you
extract these phytonutrients
now you can also add olive oil so you
cut your cucumber on your salad add
olive oil and you'll extract it
that way as well but these are the three
ways to enhance the phytonutrients
from plants in general thanks for
watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto but is it
simple
it's super simple we hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it